rico
corren
en mexico nueve de cada diez empresas
mueren en su primer año de operación
este en 2016 me conmovió me movió
muchísimo porque yo me encontraba ante
un inminente y rotundo fracaso y yo
volteaba a ver a mi alrededor
preguntándome qué es lo que lo que
sucede con estas empresas con estas
personas que no logran lo que se
proponen aun cuando tienen todo a su
favor y mejor aún la pregunta que yo
quería responderme porque para la otra
ya tenía muchísima información me
encontraba muy en contacto con el
ecosistema emprendedor de la región y de
méjico y sabía las cinco razones por las
cuales fracasamos en nuestro primer año
operación los días errores que no
debemos de cometer en tu emprendimiento
existe un patrón sobre cómo actúan como
piensan estos emprendedores estas
personas que se consideran exitosas y
que logran lo que se proponen y esta
llamamos fórmula del éxito y es una
fórmula que bueno parte de una pregunta
qué es
qué es el éxito
[Música]
entrevistamos a algunos que nos
respondieron que para ellos el éxito era
tener un apellido del cual sus hijos se
sintieran orgullosos
para otros era ser un bato coherente y
morir recta do como alguien que actuó
como pensaba y como decía para otros el
éxito de ver con su disposición de
tiempo y para otras era haber construido
una familia una propia definición de
vida
cuando concluimos con esta serie de
preguntas nos dimos cuenta que la
definición de éxito no es universal no
es esta definición de el logro de
consecuencias o metas estar en el camino
correcto porque de ser así la siguiente
pregunta sería cuáles son tus metas
cuáles son tus objetivos cuál es el
camino correcto
jorge bucay nos dice que el ect
y ciudad tiene que ver con responderte
tres preguntas quién soy a dónde voy con
quién voy y en ese orden porque a veces
confundimos el camino por la persona con
la que voy si voy con el hijo el camino
así voy con el hijo el camino b y a
partir de ahí lo que es el éxito para mí
el éxito es una definición única y
auténtica muy personal que nos requiere
un verdadero tiempo y un momento de
inspiración para llegar a conectar con
lo que verdaderamente deseamos en la
vida
la fórmula del éxito parte precisamente
de que el emprendedor tenga una claridad
de quién es y adónde va
lo demás es aplicar la fórmula del éxito
y que exista esta fórmula del éxito la
fórmula del éxito consiste en una triada
y esa tríada son tres elementos es
pilares que son el saber el poder y el
querer que son estos tres aspectos el
primero saber punto de esta
investigación descubrimos que saber
significa donde hoy y a dónde voy todos
estos personajes entrevistados y todos
los que conocemos quedan atrás
te daban una visión muy clara 5 a 10
algunos hasta 30 años que te ponen la
mitad porque todavía tienen actuar 70
años se sigan hablando de 30 años más
en la era de la inmediatez esto es una
de las grandes áreas de oportunidad
porque creemos que las cosas se hicieron
de la noche a la mañana que va a llegar
una gran idea y que haciendo una
aplicación web las cosas se van a crear
en un día facebook y über no se hicieron
de la noche a la mañana pero creemos en
esta regla inmediatez que ocurre por eso
algunos de estos emprendedores nos
decían paciencia sobre la tendencia la
paciencia sólo va a surgir cuando tengo
una clara ciencia de dónde estoy sé a
dónde voy
[Música]
saber significa tener habilidad una vez
que ya sé qué camino quiero recorrer lo
siguiente es decir y estar dispuesto a
10.000 horas de experiencia práctica
sí es cierto la pasión es la que te
despierta en la noche y te dice ya sea
esto me quiero dedicar y siento una
emoción tremenda cuando hablo que lo mío
es la cantada pero el siguiente paso es
cuál es tu experiencia cuál es tu
talento la mayoría de los listados
entrevistamos a algunos artistas cuánto
tiempo transcurrió tu primera exposición
internacional 10 años con black vuela en
su libro de outline ers quería
descubrirse al líder si estos grandes
genios nacían o se hacían y descubrió
que en promedio aria 10 mil horas de
experiencia práctica que más o menos son
cinco años dedicándole ocho horas a esto
que he decidido que es tu camino por
cierto moza empezó a componer desde los
siete años tocaba el piano desde muy
chiquito pero no fue hasta los 21
después de 10.000 horas de experiencia
acumulada que compitas grandes obras
maestras que esa trascendieron la
historia de la música
y muchos otros casos más
[Música]
a la salida de un concierto una señora
se acerca y le dice a paco de lucía para
que daría mi vida por tocar con usted
toca y paco le respondió señora eso
mismo hice yo di mi vida para tocar como
toco
el saber se indica donde ser constantes
muchas veces tenemos estas voces a
nuestro alrededor que nos dicen es que
no lo has logrado porque no le echas
ganas y lo único que vamos a obtener si
no tenemos claridad del objetivo pues es
echarle ganas desvelarnos y conducir
rápido al lugar donde no deseamos llegar
la constancia viene después de haber
definido qué es el éxito para mí
y esa gran idea que muchos estamos que
porque soy yo va a llegar en algún
momento producto de la inspiración pues
facundo menem neurocientífico nos dice
pues desafortunadamente la inspiración
es para los amateurs porque esa gran
idea ese momento eureka ese momento ajá
sólo llega después de tres procesos
estudiados científicamente uno es la
preparación y dice en esa área
tienes que estar muy preparado y esta
fase generalmente dura daños las grandes
ideas han llegado en personas que
estaban muy preparadas con un talento y
un expertise después viene una fase que
se llama incubación que es donde tu
cerebro empieza a generar esa
alternativa de solución a este dilema al
que lo has metido y quieres encontrar y
quiere solucionar y quieres y la
creatividad desatar pero dice pero es
cuando tú se pone en off cuando te
permites tener este momento de sentarte
frente a la televisión de ir en el lado
del copiloto y no pensar en nada
observar el contexto desconectarte
aburrirte
tu cerebro inconsciente
estrenar la información
presenta una idea
qué es el éxito para ti dónde estás y a
dónde vas
cuántas horas de experiencia acumulada
llevas
es algo de lo que esta primera fila en
la fórmula del éxito saber y 2 poder y
mucho se ha investigado en muchos
excluidos de cuáles son esos recursos
que se requieren para poder lograr el
éxito y lo que se concluyó es que no
necesariamente tiene que ver con el tema
del dinero o con el tema de la
tecnológica o las grandes ideas que
podamos tener el elemento más importante
de todos estos para lograr el éxito es
tu equipo quién es tu equipo cuál es tu
fortaleza al colaborar para la
integración de tu equipo y a veces
cuando vemos emprendedores que fracasan
en su primer año de operación pues
sprint es precisamente porque cuando
iniciamos iniciamos solos y pues después
de llenas de una posibilidad de crecer y
no puedes porque estás solo pero lo
mejor a google main se está ahí que te
decía mejor solo que mal bañado lo que
puedes hacer es asociarte y entonces
a colaborar de una manera adecuada desde
un pensamiento ganar-ganar o no hay
trato
había steve jobs su empresa no hubiera
surgido si no hubiera sido por bosnia
esto lo sabía michael jordan por eso
cuando amenazaban con correr a phil
jackson su mentor decía si se va él me
voy yo michael jordan no hubiera podido
lograr lo que logro si no hubiera sido
por su gran equipo scary pitan y rothman
bien esto
como hemos aprendido a desarrollar estas
habilidad es para reconocer
necesito sumar la y hay un juego básico
de roles dentro de un equipo que es
fundamental reconocer uno es el del
vendedor que es el desafiador del
estatus que le encante estar en la calle
viendo observando reconociendo que están
haciendo otros y ese no lo sientes en un
escritorio ni de chiste porque sienten
que
y
el perfil del administrador del negocio
que es alguien
con mucha tendencia a analizar el riesgo
a ser preventivo a ser planeado real es
el que materializa muchas de las cosas
que se le ocurren a este innovador y el
o el técnico que es el experto en esto
que vamos a desarrollar y por supuesto
nuestros pintores
como nunca en la historia de la
humanidad
una de las grandes oportunidades que
tenemos es la de aprender a compartir
más allá de competir y estos son los
equipos que están logrando transformar
la realidad de países y de comunidades
enteras
porque aprendieron
qué es la colaboración lo único que nos
va a llevar a lograr eso que nos hemos
propuesto los inversionistas no lo dicen
yo no yo no es que no tenga ideas porque
yo sea gran idea se la doy a alguien
equipo y esa idea va directo al fracaso
mi garantía del dinero que yo invierta
en un proyecto la única que tengo es que
sea un equipo que después de varios
fracasos
junto porque han descubierto la manera
de colaborar y a pesar de sus
diferencias entender que son estas
mismas las que hacen que un equipo sea
valioso
a un equipo buen equipo yo le doy una
idea que a lo mejor no es tan buena y
esa idea se va a transformar
el talento gana partidos pero el trabajo
en equipo y la inteligencia ganan
campeonatos tienes a tu equipo completo
has reconocido cuáles son tus fortalezas
qué fortalezas requieres de los demás
quién es tu mentor aquí en las remotas
estas inquietudes o estas grandes
intenciones que tienes tu filosofía es
la de compartir más allá de competir
esta fórmula que estoy compartiendo
pues descubrimos que no era de personas
extraordinarias sino era de personas
ordinarias que ya tenían una claridad
que cuando llegaban a integrar a su
equipo
a través de su talento
mostraban también un gran compromiso
sobre esto que habían decidido era su
camino y era su definición de éxito la
dedicación y la entrega se refleja en
nuestra agenda cuánto de nuestro tiempo
realmente le dedicamos a esto que hemos
decidido qué es lo que es mi vida
algunos de los entrevistados nos decía
es que ser empresario o tener este
proyecto no es un estilo de vida es un
proyecto de vida y se refleja porque te
dedicas a eso la pasión es relevante
pero es tan solo una llama que enciende
pero el reflejo de lo que realmente
queremos comprometernos está en esto que
transpiramos si a un alpinista hay que
estar dispuesto a pagar el precio
esta fórmula del éxito nos invita a
transformar nuestra conversación a verde
nos rodeamos y esta mañana yo los invito
a que empezamos a hacer el mundo que
queremos ver gracias